spider-man into the spider versus Sony's
latest attempt at bringing the
webslinger to the big screen this time
in animated form and from the
perspective this time of Miles Morales
in his first feature film when he's
bitten by a radioactive spider he
stumbles across a machine that allows
the parallel universes that contain
other spider-man and spider women to
collide and in so doing he runs into a
bunch of different spider people and
they all have to team up to go against
the kingpin Sony has been disappointing
me consistently with their incarnations
of spider-man and most recently venom
ever since spider-man 3 homecoming was
good but that was sort of a cross with
Marvel and Sony this time however I was
excited because I've always been a fan
of spider-man in animation form the old
spider-man show from the 90s is great
and I love the unique look of the
animation I saw featured in the trailers
and so I was excited to see the movie
and I'm so glad to say this is great I
think this might be my favorite
spider-man film since Raimi's I liked it
even more than homecoming I think it has
better storytelling I think the
characters are more fleshed out I think
as a narrative it's considerably more
impactful and the overabundant
storylines threatened to wort the
narrative but they didn't everything
felt cohesive and I think the glue that
held this movie together is the comedy
it's surprisingly hilarious in many
different ways each character that's
introduced they have this way of telling
their backstory and it's very funny
every time they do it and it creates
this consistency that you expect and
when something changes in that
consistency it becomes humorous and so
it's not just like here's a new
character here's their backstory here's
why you should care about them okay
let's get on to the fight scenes they
find ways to use humor to really boost
the impact of their stories but the film
isn't afraid to get serious either
especially with Miles Morales he has a
very difficult relationship with his
father who's a cop and his uncle who his
father doesn't really get along with
anymore and he'd rather hang out with
his uncle and he's into graffiti and he
has a hard time talking to people at
school he's being forced to go to this
fancy school that doesn't feel
comfortable in and I found myself
genuinely care
about him by the end of the film and his
arc was very well realized it's not one
of those instantly perfect heroes that
we've seen so often lately in superhero
movies where once you get your powers
alright let's just run around and punch
things no it takes a long time for miles
to get used to what he's dealing with
it's hard for him to adjust to this new
life he feels like a real person the
animation too is spectacular so many
things are happening at once as
characters are talking in their minds
you get the little comic book yellow
boxes of the thoughts when people knock
on a door or there's a very exaggerated
sound effect you see the text appear
behind them just like in a comic book
panel without a doubt this is the most
comic book II spider-man movie ever just
based off of the people who appear in it
and I'm not gonna tell you any of them
but there's a lot of great things that
happen in the movie some really amazing
cameos and a top-tier end credits scene
please stay for it because my theater
was rolling it's amazing there's certain
things I want in a spider-man movie
besides the obvious like a compelling
story and good characters and good Vil
and good hero there's something about
the character that really needs to be
there and it's this innocence combined
with world weariness I think because
spider-man as a person and Peter Parker
there it's a character that's been
beaten down so much that's dealt with so
much in their lives but they're
still maintaining some optimism and
Mayas Morales is very much so the same
he's a character dealing with so much
but he's able to pull himself out of it
and that's why you love him and the
Peter Parker character in the film and
the Miles Morales character in
particular are so well realized the
filmmakers clearly understand what the
message behind the character of
spider-man means to people and they used
it to great extents to boost the film's
dramatic power as well as to humor the
action sequences are enthralling this is
one of the better spider-man movies
without a doubt my only real issue with
the movie was kingpin I thought he was
very underdeveloped underutilized he was
sort of a big hulking villain who every
once in a while you saw a peek behind
the curtain but it's what we all know
and what we all expect from from King
I think they could have done a better
job with the villain but at the same
time there are so many callous heroes in
this movie that I can understand that
you just don't want to over saturate
your film with characterization to the
point where you forget what the movies
actually about but that's really my only
issue with spider-man into the
spider-verse and I have not wanted a
sequel to a spider-man movie this much
since Tobey Maguire and Sam Raimi made
that movie in 2002 I'm gonna give
spider-man into the spider-verse and a
this movie was everything I wanted and
more and I can't wait for you guys to
check it out thank you so much as always
for watching and if you like this you
can click right here and get steppen
eyes
[Music]